[Musik]
eine pro-palästinensische demonstration
wie man sieht
und doch ist etwas anders an diesem
samstag in washington
denn die gewalt in israel beklagen auch
orthodoxie
sie dürfen am sabbat nicht mit der
presse reden aber auf ihren schildern
kritisieren sie die vertreibung von
palästinensern durch jüdische siedler
auch sarah miedler und ihre freundin
demonstrieren als zitat juden für die
freiheit der palästinenser in der
jüdischen gemeinschaft in amerika ist
etwas in bewegung geraten besonders
junge leute protestieren für gleichheit
und würde aller menschen im nahen osten
israel ische regierung tut geschieht im
namen der sicherheit
sie behauptet es gehe um den schutz der
juden aber ich glaube nicht dass wir für
die sicherheit der juden palästinenser
unterdrücken müssen
in new york haben wir uns mit einem
religiösen juden verabredet der zweimal
täglich in die synagoge geht peter
weinert war einst blühender vertreter
eines jüdischen staates israel
jetzt gilt er als eine der wichtigsten
stimmen des liberalen flügels im
amerikanischen jugend in der
israelischen regierung und bei den
anführern der amerikanischen juden sehen
wir eine tendenz die palästinenser in
einer art nazi rolle darzustellen sie
also immer als treibende kraft für einen
möglichen völkermord zu sehen und diese
schablone dient dann als lizenz zu sagen
um zu überleben können wir alles tun was
wir tun müssen
auf diese weise wird unterdrückung
gericht fordert einen staat israel mit
gleichen rechten für alle ein jüdisches
volk das israel als rechtmäßiger heimat
reklamiere müsse gleiches auch den
palästinensern zu gestehen
es scheint eine sehr bittere ironie dass
israels regierung und jüdischer anführer
den palästinensern sagen ihr seid vor 75
jahren von hier vertrieben worden oder
eure eltern oder großeltern aber das
solltet ihr vergessen euch einfach
einfügen in ein fremdes land und euren
wunsch auf heimkehr aufgeben natürlich
macht sich breit in der jüdischen
gemeinde amerikas damit auch feind aber
bei seinen wöchentlichen zoom talks
begrüßt er jeden freitag mehr als 100
zuhörer vor allem juden die wir aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht zeigen dürfen
niemand von ihnen mit zweifelt das recht
israels sich gegen die mörderischen
raketenangriffe der terror organisation
hamas zu verteidigen
aber der ewige zyklus von gewalt und
gegengewalt mit opfern und zerstörung
auf beiden seiten entspringe auch einer
politik der israelischen regierung die
eskalation für ihre innenpolitischen
zwecke nutzen
der druck der us regierung auf beide
seiten für einen waffenstillstand zeigt
dass amerikas unerschütterliche
unterstützung für israels führung nicht
mehr selbstverständlich ist
außenminister blinken betont dabei ein
wort immer wieder ekel gleich wir
glauben dass israelis und palästinenser
gleichermaßen verdienen in sicherheit zu
leben das gleiche maß an freiheit
chancen und demokratie zu genießen und
mit würde behandelt zu werden
zunächst sind das nur worte aber im
amerikanischen kongress wird der ruf
nach taten laut in beiden demokratischer
partei wächst der druck auf den
präsidenten am end aria fordern den
stopp der waffenlieferungen nach israel
dessen führung sie als apartheids
regierung bezeichnet auch die
demonstrationen der letzten wochen bevor
das umdenken in washington wer gegen die
diskriminierung von minderheiten in den
usa protestiert sympathisiert meist mit
den palästinensern es gibt auch
antisemitische gewalt einige arabisch
stämmige jugendliche griffen jüdische
mitbürger an
aber solche auswüchse meint peter
weinert würden schnell missbraucht um
legitime proteste als antisemitisch
abzustempeln in den usa und in
deutschland
wenn die deutschen mutig mit ihrer
moralischen verpflichtung aus ihrer
geschichte umgehen wollen dann müssen
sie die freiheit und würde von menschen
verteidigen selbst wenn ein jüdischer
staat diese unterdrückung verübt
[Musik]
frieden für die welt heißt die musik die
listen es komponiert hat wir besuchen
die pianistin ihren mann raffi und ihre
tochter real in new york die new york
times hat an diesem tag die fotos der
jüdischen und palästinensischen kinder
abgedruckt dem jüngsten konflikt getötet
wurden für familie magnus ein zeichen
viele unserer freunde denken so wie hier
nicht alle sind juden
aber wenn die new york times so etwas
macht dann zeigt dass eine veränderung
die black jewels matter bewegung so
erzählte uns jahre hat sie motiviert ist
fest überzeugt dass auch in israel
selbst immer mehr menschen ein
friedliches miteinander ball
glauben sie dass die israelis ein gutes
leben haben
sie stecken alle in dieser lage fest
glauben sie dass ein soldat der damit
angst in den augen steht dass der sich
sein leben so gewünscht hätte wenn es
nicht all diese propaganda gelbe das ist
alles eine lüge
es ist kein gutes leben weder für
israelis noch für palästinenser
donald trump habe premierminister
netanjahu freie hand gelassen mit seiner
siedlungspolitik die zwei-staaten-lösung
zu zerstören die mangels familie fordert
einen gemeinsamen demokratischen staates
israel mit gleichen rechten für ein
genie dieser welt könnte in diesem
winzigen gebiet eine grenze ziehen die
zwei überlebensfähige staaten ermöglicht
wir wissen dass es einen gemeinsamen
staat geben kann und dass die menschen
das verstehen müssen
und wenn jemand sagt ich sei eine
verräterin oder eine böse jüdin dann
sagst du halt ich bin ein mensch der
menschen liebt das nehmen wir mit zurück
nach washington kann das gespräch suchen
und lösungsmöglichkeiten
auch wenn er noch so unlösbar erscheint
dieser konflikt geben sich sarah mittler
und eine wachsende zahl der
amerikanischen juden nicht mehr
zufrieden mit dem status quo im nahen
osten